il y a des enfants qui
pensent que je suis cool et qui suivent chacun de mes mouvements
et j'espère donc pouvoir les influencer pour qu'ils
fassent le bien et rendent leur vie encore plus grande
en donnant de la
[Musique] à une
fille et encore aujourd'hui, je parle à
Dieu tous les jours  c'était très compris
et c'est tellement incroyable
[Musique]
maintenant, j'étais tellement fan de tous ses
films en grandissant et j'étais en quelque sorte seulement
autorisé à regarder ce genre de films, je
n'étais pas vraiment autorisé à regarder les
films actuels et elle  J'avais une classe incroyable,
une grâce et une humilité chez elle
que j'essaie d'adopter chaque
jour.
[Musique]
J'aime créer des choses, tu sais, j'aime
dessiner, j'aime créer des histoires et
écrire des chansons et des choses comme ça, donc dans
à l'avenir, j'essaierai différentes choses,
mais l'essentiel sera toujours
avec la musique parce que bien sûr, c'était
heureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique
] [Musique
] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] L'
UNICEF est une très grande organisation qui
donne le plus d'argent aux
enfants vulnérables et je suis juste heureuse de pouvoir en faire
partie.
[Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je me lève et je marche avec Hillary Je
crois en son avenir, sa vision Je
crois en ses politiques Je crois en l'
égalité des droits pour les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]
et ce qui me fait continuer, c'est avant
tout de rester ouvert à Dieu et à l'
univers pour faire, vous savez, le travail,
qu'il s'agisse d'un travail de santé mentale, d'un
travail spirituel, vous savez, d'un travail relationnel
[Musique]